hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
this week in our Saturday shenanigans I
am playing with Zakir but I forgot to
record Zac's audio so Zach will be
replaced by an automated voice and the
good thing about this is that I can make
Zach say anything I want
isn't that right Zach use code Adam are
you in the fortnight's shop I agree new
game mode Oh airplanes are back okay
okay let's try this out this could be
good Oh your arms up in the air honestly
you have this cute hello my name is Zach
greatest pilot in the business come on
it's a game changer the minigun isn't it
absolutely
I feel so good game changer I don't like
the overheat no but stick with and put
office
oh-hoh on 2008 points I really do like
this game modes brilliant last to last
to just keep on the back will keep on
the my brilliant want to go what to go
come on
yeah like this game boys
Yago scales we're gonna do about it
Oh your stupid puzzle Hellmouth what
happens if we explain this is it this is
it oh okay okay there can be only one
Gigi's gg gg I can hear it holy Sh oh
okay it's pretty cool what you have to
do
I forgot six just work your piece of
turd this doesn't do something freaking
brilliant when it's done I'll be very
annoyed yeah did it does anything happen
literally nothing happy a what a waste
of my life
woo I don't know I thought the guy from
taken was gonna pick up the phone and
send me a message I will find you
and I will kill you next time we get
weapons before we play with the
oversized telephones please shoot him
105 off both of them don't shoot him
let me run him like a sweaty builder and
steal your kill shield cigar these one
hit you do your thing Zach WTF I want to
be a pro like you one day Zachary look
at his builds I'll show him out to build
we got bro Barney a bang us a built boom
let's see those amazing building skills
again instant erection stain there
Wow let's go Adam yeah we really did
well there wow I learned what the word
flaccid means today the word plus it
gone and what does it mean it means
board right are you are you throwing me
you do that on purpose are you know what
flaccid with no I'm not signify this
second I'm coming
plus it means board I know it does this
isn't real
I call board is that Siri what does
Fassett mean a part of the body softly
oh I've been saying fasted all day oh
it's got the new runes skin I want to
have a look see let me have a look okay
looks good
does your friend have one too where is
your friend you were obviously running
back to somebody
did you read me just take me out on him
you are it had to be done horrible last
one which one who shall we pick up the
last guy mm-hmm
oh good okay oh he's resin help come on
bloom today bloom is awesome it's one
hit one hit nice whoo we're popping off
that game dude I killed the entire
server all six people for pro duo's I
don't think they've got comms again
Denis the bright red skin down there get
down there let me get in get in get in
get in get in
yeah four night season eight skills adds
add the song so sorry dude I'm so sorry
always go the rest can you get the res
he's got his wall up he's left his ass
hanging out
penis shot free Teletoon oh it's coming
up hi mate Oh
why can't I still not use a shotgun we
see soccer skins here they are the Kiwis
players ever feel like I'm murdering it
[Music]
thank you brother dusty evil sting I can
imagine like spaghetti that's for me
give you a golden weapons I'm a nice guy
yeah I don't get take something for
nothing I'm sorry about still not happy
dude this is why I took it I will show
you now see him yeah a little chickies
new book thanks for playing what you
doing Zachary fighting can I join in
I do you wanna wanna be - yeah cause
guys I'll leave the other one
[Music]
and time on your thinking there we go
nicely done yay do a wild Zach a wild
Zack built baffling a duo Adam can you
help you'll be right Adam Adam Adam
he'll be right
it doesn't need help if they're on
ground level I'll shoot if he builds is
yours
he's all yours building yeah can Zach
pickaxe nope sorry kill stealer that's
what they call me why are you bullying
me how did it go I see oh there he is
oh I get why you run now I get it indeed
hang on yeah yeah stop it
and another squats coming in now what
kind of a guy are you oh you're okay
okay building now you're running did you
use all your months well I'm not going
that way right side P train by side peak
you live and learn
Caleb Caleb my own and Kino hang in it
we're gonna do your friends down you
gonna go help him he sure plays like
that no no like this not like this deep
deep Bloody Bloody Bloody that's the
most British thing ever
bloody but hey you made it to the end of
another one of these Saturday
shenanigans thank you very much for
watch this much appreciated as always on
fortnight videos I'd like to thank these
people who use my code a tomorrow in the
fortnight shot it helps me out a lot and
makes these weekly videos possible thank
you very much I hugely appreciate it
anyway it's been a pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]